CBS News is getting an exclusive look at
the FBI's new effort to track police use
of force this comes as some departments
are accused of bias and brutality
yesterday we revealed a growing number
of police officers in America's big
cities say they have implicit bias
training but it is hard to prove it's
working that's partly because the
federal government has never tracked how
often police use force
Jeff PJs met exclusively with the FBI
team on a mission to do just that
he's in Ferguson Missouri where he
continues our series policing in America
five years after Ferguson Jeff what did
you find out well good morning I was
there after Ferguson after those
protests when the FBI broached the idea
of gathering this kind of information
because at the time FBI officials were
trying to explain the trends in use of
force but they just didn't have the
information that they needed and so this
database is supposed to change that the
concern is that the FBI won't get the
data that it needs to draw key
conclusions because the whole process is
voluntary for police officers
split-second decisions about using a
weapon can mean life or death for the
officer and the public in the recent
mass shooting in Dayton Ohio officers
saved lives by quickly taking down the
suspect okay but in other cases like the
2016 shooting death of volando Castille
in Minnesota claims of excessive force
can lead to termination for the officer
either way it's their training that lays
the foundation for how officers respond
now an FBI team in Bridgeport West
Virginia is gathering use of force data
from the roughly 18,000 police
departments across the country
how important is this database in terms
of training and preventing use of force
incidents incredibly important my Cody
Leon is the assistant director of the
FBI's criminal justice information
services division there's two primary
reasons for doing this to make sure that
we're transparent to the communities
that we serve and this will help our law
enforcement professionals across the
country establish training it's going to
help them better deal with these
incidents to being capital are you
operating from the mindset that use of
force incidents can be prevented our
hope is that they can the use of forces
is a is a last choice you think it is I
do I absolutely do DeLeon says his team
will be tracking deadly force force that
results in serious injury and force
where an officer's weapon is discharged
in the direction of a person he says
they'll also be gathering information on
the circumstances surrounding each
incident including the race and physical
condition of those involved despite the
wide range of data they're after there
are concerns that the information may
have a fundamental flaw because it's
voluntary departments can choose to
participate and they don't have to
present everything David Johnson is a
social psychologist who studies officers
use of force decisions what we need
moving forward is to make this kind of
reporting mandatory and to standardize
it how do you prevent these departments
across the country from submitting false
information if you have a voluntary
system if a law enforcement agency is
not reporting truthfully I think that we
quickly discovered through not just the
media but in the communities following
that that track but you're not gonna
call them on it if they submit false
information
what we're not monitoring them you're
not no we're gonna rely on them to be
truthful and I would tell you that the
law enforcement community expects that
from each other yeah but is that good
enough for the public yes
the FBI hopes to have use of force data
from 40% of the police departments
across the country by January of 2020 at
that time they'll be able to make that
information available to the public
online however the public will not get
the raw data it will only see the trends
Anthony no Geoff thank you there will be
more of Jeff's exclusive report tonight
on the CBS Evening News then tomorrow on
CBS this morning will share our
interview with Michael Brown's father as
part of our policing in America Series
five years after Ferguson you'll also
hear from the Ferguson community and
from top officials in st. Louis about
what has changed and what is not